Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky,
the billionaire founder of Kind,
returns to the Tank.
You can grow yourself
out of business
if you're
not cautious here.
Daniel, we look up to you
a tremendous amount.
Okay, boys,
no more "Kumbaya."
Oh.
Alright, here.
I want you to look me
very closely in the eyes.
Seriously?
What?
There you go!
I'm trying to come up with
a reasonable deal on the fly.
I just gave you one.
With all due respect,
that seems nuts.
Whoa!
♪ Dunh‐dunh‐dunh duh! ♪
Whoo!
I'll give you
a million dollars.
More, more, more.
Sharks are expensive,
my friend.
Let's go!
♪♪
My name is David Scharfman,
and I'm from Madison, Wisconsin.
I grew up in a family
of cheesemakers.
My mom and dad bought
a little cheese company in 1991.
Growing up around a cheese
company was a lot of fun.
I got to go out on demos,
selling cheese,
handing out samples.
When I was 16, I started working
in the factory,
doing jobs that no one else
wanted to do.
My dad wanted everyone to know
that I wasn't getting
any special treatment.
Eventually,
I graduated into sales jobs
that didn't require a hairnet.
I loved working
at my parents' cheese company,
but I wanted to set out
on my own path.
I tried my hand at bringing
Wisconsin cheese to Asia,
but that ultimately failed.
So then I tried to make
Wisconsin cheese in Asia,
and that also failed.
I applied to business school.
After I graduated, I became
a consultant in New York City.
Ultimately wanted to be back
in small business,
and that's when my wife and I
had a great idea,
and all roads
lead back to cheese.
I need an investment
from the Sharks
to get more people
to try my product.
As soon as people try it,
they love it,
they keep buying it.
My family and I have invested
over a million dollars in this.
If this product fails, a lot
of people will lose their jobs,
a lot of people will lose money.
It's important for me
to make sure I justify
the risk my dad took on me.
I want to make him proud
and turn this risk
into a huge success.
♪♪
Oh!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Cheesehead.
Hi.
My name is David Scharfman,
and I'm the owner of
Just The Cheese.
And I'm asking for
a half a million dollars
for 5% of my business.
Wow.
Now, I know
what you're thinking.
A half million dollars
is a lot of cheddar!
Ha‐ha!
And you're right.
But our business is cheese,
our cheese is delicious,
and our business is booming.
So, you know when you make
a grilled cheese sandwich,
the best part is the cheese
that melts off into the pan
and gets crunchy?
Well, most people look at that
and think,
"Man, I wish I could eat
just the cheese."
Since we're a family
of cheesemakers,
we look at it and think,
"Huh. How could we turn that
into a snack bar?"
So, let me show you
how we do it.
First, we start
with Wisconsin milk.
Make our own fresh cheese
in‐house.
Shred just a little bit
into a cookie‐cutter mold.
Pop it in the oven.
And that is it.
No rice, no fillers.
It's just the cheese.
Comes in two bars in a pack.
It's the perfect grab‐and‐go
snack for anytime, anywhere.
And because it's just the...
Cheese.
Cheese.                  Cheese.
...everyone will love it.
So, now for the best part ‐‐
let's try 'em.
Let's try 'em.
Feel free to read
the ingredient list.
It's a quick read and short.
Different flavors?
Yep.
Aged Cheddar
is our top seller.
If you like stronger flavors,
I'd start there.
Grilled Cheese
is more mild.
Really good.
I have to admit,
I've had this before.
Really?!
Herjavec: What?
Yes.
I bought it on Amazon.
You are not alone
with that.
We sell between 400 and 700
boxes a day on Amazon.
It's very cheesy.
I can't believe
it's so simple.
How many calories
per bar?
Per bar? 75.
That's it?
That's it? Wow.
In the package
with two bars,
150 calories,
8 grams of protein.
It's sugar‐free,
gluten‐free.
Why can't anybody
knock you off?
I mean, you're doing
something so simple.
Anybody can do this,
right?
Theoretically, yes,
but there's a lot of science
that goes into cheesemaking,
and we have some extremely
talented people.
But this is everywhere.
No, but, David, David,
there's a ton of brands
out there ahead of you.
I think your brand is better.
I love Just The Cheese.
You're very direct.
But there's like three
or four big, gigantic
companies that have ‐‐
Daniel, and they're
just cheese also?
Yeah.
So, there are
two big competitors,
both of whom have
private‐equity overlords.
[ Chuckles ]
One competitor
also puts quinoa, brown rice,
and oat bran in it,
so it's cheaper and it tastes
more like a cracker.
For reference,
we're usually ranked
in, like, the mid‐300s
on all of Amazon grocery.
They're ranked
in the 18,000 range.
Well, all that matters
is your sales.
Tell us about
your business.
Sure.
So, last year, we launched.
First year in existence,
we did $3.5 million in sales.
Hello.
Wow!
Year‐to‐date,
we are already at 3.7,
and we still have
four months of the year left.
And how many stores
are you in?
700 stores right now,
plus 1,300 from a prominent
convenience store chain,
7‐Eleven.
I got my first P. O. s today.
What?
So, what, you did
$3.5 million year‐to‐date
out of only 700 stores?
And Amazon, so ‐‐
Plus ‐‐
Okay, break that down.
I will back up, 'cause I think
chronology will help.
I sort of keep
an eye on the family business.
So we had been tinkering around
after we saw Whisps,
so we talked to my dad about it
and said,
"Hey, we used to do something
similar back in the '90s
for the Atkins craze.
When the Atkins craze died,
the product cratered.
So we looked at
relaunching it,
and my wife had the foresight
to spot the keto trend.
And when keto took off,
we were pretty much
the only game in town.
So, did you raise
any investment?
Nope. This family has
self‐funded this completely.
How much did you put in
to get to this point?
We've probably invested a total
of maybe a million dollars.
What does it cost you to make?
What do you wholesale it for?
So, at our current volume,
95 cents ‐‐
And what do you
sell it for?
$1.27,
retailing for $1.99.
Depending on the SKU,
we make between 17% and 20%.
That's it?
When we wholesale it
to a brick‐and‐mortar store,
it's 25.
That's terrible margins.
What's the plan
to make more margin on it?
So, if I sell
40,000 boxes a month...
And what's the cost?
...at that volume...
it would be 75 cents per,
at $1.27.
So my margin increases
substantially as I grow.
If there was ever
a royalty deal, this is it.
Greiner: Royalty?
There's no way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's in stores
everywhere.
Excuse me, Lori.
He doesn't need that.
I'd like to make
an offer.
Thank you.
Okay.
[ Chuckles ]
Look, I don't have a cheese
provider in my portfolio.
[ Laughter ]
I have a lot of wine.
Wine, cheese ‐‐ you kind of get
what I'm talking about here.
I'll give you
the $500,000,
and I want a 20 cent royalty
per bar, which is ‐‐
He's got no margins.
You can't ‐‐
Herjavec: [ Laughs ]
Silence
while I make an offer.
He can decide whether he wants
to take it or not.
Alright.
Make it already.
I don't need the noise from
the cheese factory back here.
I'm trying to.
[ Chuckles ]
I'll give you the $500,000
for a 20 cent royalty,
and I will give you tremendous
marketing leverage on this.
Because I think this could be
a fantastic business
if you can get
more distribution.
With all due respect,
I think that that piggybacks
off the hard work
we've already done.
But I can add
a lot of value here,
bringing this
into my portfolio
and making you
a "Shark Tank" company.
And our interests
are totally aligned.
I'm only asking
for a little cheese on my beak
every time we sell a bar.
[ Chuckles ]
Look, I think you've
done an amazing job
getting it out there.
I think you're probably
one of the fastest
zero‐to‐million‐plus in sales
we've had on the show.
But I don't like
the taste of it.
It's not a knock on it.
It's just a personal thing
for me.
Yep.
So, you know,
only for that reason,
I'm out,
but I congratulate you
on the success.
I think
Kevin's offer smells.
he cut the cheese.
[ Laughs ]
Ah!
I was waiting for someone
to go there.
Lubetzky:
David, here's my thoughts.
I think you have
a superior brand,
but farmers of cheese
are looking and shopping around
to see who would like them
to make this product,
so there's gonna be
more entrants.
I just don't think
there's space, and I'm out.
Okay.
So, I like your packaging
a lot.
I think it's really smart.
It's really good.
But I'm seeing
so many places,
ads for things
that are competitive,
and I'm not sure
who's going to wind up
being the leaders in this.
And for half a million dollars
at 5%,
I don't feel solid enough
to invest,
so I'm out.
Alright.
I'll give you another angle,
and this is what dawned on me.
At a $10 million valuation,
even if you sell the company
for $50 million
and I get
five times my money,
my total upside is
$2.5 million over $500,000.
That's not enough for the risk
that's involved.
I just don't see a way
to overcome that.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Yeah.
All is not lost,
because the Yellow Cheese Road
leads back
to Mr. Wonderful.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
David has one offer on the table
for his cheese snack company,
Just The Cheese.
O'Leary:
David, to be clear,
I give you
half a million dollars,
I ask for 20 cents a bar
as a royalty,
I get no equity.
In perpetuity?
Absolutely. How else
am I gonna do this deal?
Perpetuity
is a very long time.
It's a word I like.
So, how flexible are you
in the royalty fee itself
and the term of the deal?
I'm not negotiating
against myself.
I'm trying to come up with
a reasonable deal on the fly.
I just gave you one.
David,
make a counter.
Here,
I'll help him.
I'll give you
half a million dollars
for 15 cents a bar.
♪♪
Still perpetuity?
What are you
going to suggest?
So, I'd like to make
a reasonable offer,
so I'd like a pen and paper,
'cause I don't want
to make any offer
that's insulting to any of you.
Here you go.
Oop.
So, if you were
going to take...
O'Leary: 20 cents.
...20 cents a bar...
Yeah.
...you would get 360K,
based on my Amazon sales
from last year.
Yeah.
Mm.
That seems, for lack
of a better word, nuts.
‐Hah!
‐[ Laughs ]
I like David.
I really like David.
So, what's your counter,
then?
Well,
I'm looking at a nickel.
A nickel?
In perpetuity?
Nope ‐‐ 10 years.
A nickel for 10 years?
Wait, how many bars
did you sell last year?
Yeah.
Last year on Amazon, I did
1.8 million individual packages.
Well, I'm sticking at 15 cents
until I recoup...
$750,000.
♪♪
With all due respect,
that puts too much
short‐term cash‐flow stress
on the business.
I can't be siphoning
more and more cash out.
So, David. David,
I'll offer you $500,000.
I want 15%, no royalty.
♪♪
Yes or no?
So, while I respect
both Kevin and Lori's offers ‐‐
I'm out.
You're out?
Oh, you're out now?
I'm out.
Now you have two offers.
What do you want to do?
With all due respect,
I do appreciate
that you were the first
to give me an offer.
Yes.
But I'm gonna
have to decline.
I made that offer
'cause of the tie.
I like it.
[ Chuckles ]
Cuban:
So, back to me, David.
15% is high for me.
So I would ask
if you'd consider 7.5%.
No. 'Cause there's got to be
enough upside for me.
It needs to get to scale
in order for it to be
worth anything to anybody.
And the difference
between 8% in equity,
if we get it to scale,
is bupkes.
[ Flaps lips ]
♪♪
It's a reasonable offer.
But I'm gonna politely
and respectfully say "no."
Fair enough.
We wish you the best,
David.
O'Leary: Thank you, David.
‐David, good luck.
‐It was an interesting ride.
Greiner: Good luck, David.
It was a pleasure, guys.
Thank you so much.
♪♪
I'm feeling a little
disappointed for my wife,
my family, everyone who pours
their heart and soul
into making
such a great product.
So I'm disappointed for them
that I couldn't
bring home a deal,
but I hope they're
proud of me anyway.
♪♪
Narrator:
Earlier this season, we watched
Ron, Taylor, and Kobe Johnson
make a deal with Matt Higgins
for their portable outdoor
kitchen in a box, Tailgate N Go.
Matt?
I'm listening.
So, let me get this straight ‐‐
everybody's out but Kevin,
but you're giving a counter
to Matt?
Let's do your deal.
Let's do your deal!
Alright!
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
Ron: "Shark Tank" has
transformed Tailgate N Go
from a small business
that we started
to this monster business.
Before "Shark Tank," we'd been
in business for two years
and had about $137,000
in sales.
Now, three months
after "Shark Tank,"
we've done
$400,000 in sales.
‐What's up, Matt?
‐Welcome.
Higgins:
I've invited Tailgate N Go
out to Miami today.
Our stadium is hosting
the Super Bowl,
and there is no better place
to do a deal with the NFL
than right here.
Welcome to Miami
and the Super Bowl.
I also have here
Ryan Fitzpatrick,
quarterback
of the Miami Dolphins,
and huge fan
of the Tailgate N Go.
So, as part
of your license,
we're gonna have the rights
to all 32 team marks
and the ability to sell
nationwide and on our NFL Shop.
Higgins: To be an officially
licensed product, it means
that you could use team logos
on all your products.
It means that you use
the reach of the NFL
to put you in front of every
single NFL fan in the country.
And let's face it ‐‐ there are
hundreds of millions of them.
It's a game‐changer.
Everybody loves the game,
but it's the party
before the game
that is the big deal
for a lot of these fans,
and I think NFL fans
are gonna love it.
Dad, don't cry.
You're gonna make me cry.
Higgins:
The sky is the limit now.
We're gonna go after
other sports leagues.
We're going after
major retailers.
We are gonna be everywhere.
It's so amazing
that we've actually
reached our goal.
But we're not done yet. We have
one more surprise for you.
Higgins: We're launching
at the NFL Experience.
We're gonna put Tailgate N Go
on display,
and we are gonna sell
Tailgate N Gos.
It's a portable
modular outdoor kitchen.
‐I love it.
‐Yeah? You love it?
‐I want to cook on this.
‐I love it, too.
Taylor: We couldn't be
more thankful to "Shark Tank"
and Matt Higgins
for this experience.
We honestly feel like the
luckiest family in the world.
First sale, baby!
First sale!
[ Laughs ]
You're awesome.
Higgins: They were just given
the shot of a lifetime,
and I believe that they're gonna
make everything out of it,
'cause that's what they did
on "Shark Tank"
when they convinced me
to come back in,
and that's what they're gonna do
with the NFL.
What this family shows
is that if you work hard
and you never take "no"
for an answer,
you could literally do anything.
Together: "Shark Tank"!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are gum and mints
with an extra boost.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Kent.
And I'm Ryan.
And we're the founders of Neuro,
from Los Angeles, California.
Today
we're seeking $750,000
in exchange for 5%
of the company.
‐Whoo!
‐Okay.
When I met Kent in college,
he was studying neuroscience
and training with
the Japanese Olympic judo team.
And Ryan was
studying chemistry
and was captain of
the cross‐country
and track team.
He's a second‐degree
black belt in karate.
And he's finished
12 marathons.
He's also an artist
and has done over 40
murals around the world.
And he trains with
the U. S. Paralympic team.
I guess, if there's one word
to describe us, it would be...
More, more, more.
[ Chuckles ]
Look, we like to push
each other,
but sometimes you just need
that little extra boost.
Coffee's great, but it doesn't
fit in your pocket,
and you don't want to be
running around with it.
Oh, and don't get me started
on energy drinks.
We wanted
clean, balanced energy ‐‐
something that could be taken
anytime, anywhere.
So that's why we created
NeuroGum and NeuroMints ‐‐
for when you need
just a little more.
Using a patented
cold‐compressed method...
We use a blend of
natural caffeine...
...plus L‐theanine...
...and B6 and B12 vitamins
in each piece.
Each piece contains
as much caffeine
as half a cup of coffee.
And since you absorb it
through your mouth,
it works way faster
than drinks or supplements.
But what about the sugar?
Oh, ew. No.
GMOs?
Nope.
Alright, but is it vegan?
Yeah, of course it is.
Wow. It really is better
than a cup of coffee.
And 1/10 the price.
So, Sharks, wake up.
Don't get yourself stuck
in a sticky situation.
Now, who wants to chew on
some NeuroGum and NeuroMints?
Yeah, bring it on.
We got some samples.
‐Let's do it.
‐Bring it on.
‐Alright.
‐There you go.
It's the mints on the top,
and cinnamon...
Oh, thank you.
...and mint‐flavored gum
on the bottom.
What do you want us
to try first?
‐Try the mints first.
‐The mints are great.
‐Oh, the mints?
‐The sliding tin one.
Herjavec: How long does it
take to be effective?
5 to 10 minutes.
Lubetzky:
Are you already in stores?
Yoshimura: We are in stores ‐‐
5,500 locations.
Tell us a little
about your background.
When I was in college,
I was basically training
four to five hours a day,
trying to balance school
with my social life,
and my training
was extremely difficult.
So I was mixing supplements
in my own room.
And, obviously, we have chemists
and formulators now
to refine it,
but that was essentially v zero
of NeuroGum.
Where did you meet Ryan?
I met Kent
in Japanese class.
We automatically
just hit it off,
and then we became
best friends.
And in 2009,
I was 19 years old,
and I got in a really bad
snowboarding accident.
Oh, no.
And doctors told me
I would never walk again.
I spent the next two years
and 15 surgeries
in the hospital.
I think that was definitely
the lowest point of my life.
And, fortunately,
I had the best friends,
family in the world
that helped me get back
to where I wanted to be.
You know, Kent and I
just wanted to live more.
We wanted to do everything
that life had to offer.
And that was really
the catalyst to start NeuroGum.
Herjavec: You know, life
can change in a millisecond.
Greiner: Yeah.
Kudos to you.
I mean,
that is just so impressive.
I'm just trying to live life
to the best.
Well, here you are
on "Shark Tank." That's not bad.
So,
based on your valuation,
you must be doing
a lot of business.
We can do much better,
but we have been doing
a fantastic job this year.
We're coming up
to about four years
from starting,
launching the company.
This year, we'll do about
$3.5 million in sales.
Wow!
And we just
entered retail ‐‐
Greiner: 3‐point what?
$3.5 million in sales
this year.
What did you do
last year?
Yeah, what was ‐‐
About $1.5 million.
Bam!
[ Laughter ]
For the first 3 1/2 years
of the business,
we only focused on online
and Amazon.
So, about 33% of our customers
in the last 12 months
on our website
have bought again.
And on Amazon,
it's about 21%.
So the people who try
our product really love it.
Ryan, I got to tell you, I am
so friggin' hyper right now.
Yes! Yes!
Yes!
Let's go! I'm gonna
take you on in judo, Kent.
Deal, deal, deal!
[ Laughs ]
So, listen, walk me through
your distribution,
because the danger
with rising sales
is that they may mask
repeat sales.
Daniel, there is
a big reason why we're here,
because retail
is terrifying.
And I think we need
that marketing prowess,
the ad allowances,
the shelf talk ‐‐
all those things that
kind of come into play.
Listing fees.
Like, it's crazy.
So, we're in 5,000
of the largest ‐‐
the largest pharmacy chain
in the United States.
We're the number‐2
best‐selling product
in memory focus in CVS.
So, we retail the product
for about $3.95, $3.99,
and it costs us 67 cents to make
the NeuroGum and NeuroMints.
And so our gross margins
are high.
What is your sales
in just CVS?
It's close to half a million
so far.
I'm assuming you're
gonna tell me you're gonna
do $5 million next year?
I think we could do $10 million,
because we have...
Why?
...two large P. O. s
lined up
with two of the largest
airline companies.
Who are they?
It's Delta and JetBlue.
Lubetzky: So, guys,
some advice I want to give you,
because you can grow yourself
out of business
if you're not cautious here.
You can have an airline
get very excited,
try one order,
you go really fast,
and before you know it,
they don't reorder.
You just need to be careful
with your growth.
I love your authenticity.
You remind me of my father
because people
that survived the Holocaust,
the overwhelming majority,
they could not talk back
about their past.
My dad found a way to talk about
everything he went through,
but to always be kind,
to always be thankful,
and to always see the positive,
and I just see that in you.
But it's just not
a category
that I feel
I can connect to enough.
I'm out.
But I love everything
about you guys.
I wish you
the very, very best.
Thank you so much.
Daniel, we look up to you
a tremendous amount
at what you've done
with Kind Bar.
And you are, like,
an inspiration to us.
Okay, boys,
no more "Kumbaya."
$750,000 ‐‐ what are you
doing with the money?
So, the $750,000
is gonna go into
the marketing efforts in retail,
because that's the ‐‐
Marketing?
Guys, why are you even
talking about retail?
You have a proven model.
Why are you worth
$15 million?
Because most CPG companies right
now have been getting acquired
at 3x to 10x multiple
on top‐line revenue,
and that's what
we're talking about.
But that doesn't have to do
with where you're at right now.
♪♪
Okay. Here's my challenge
with it.
The value of this company
would have to grow by so much
for me to make any money
at my 5%.
Right.
I think what we're ‐‐
We're just getting started
on the retail,
and I think,
back to your point ‐‐
why don't we just stay
as an online business? ‐‐
is we want to really make this
into a national brand, and ‐‐
Takes a lot of money
to do that, my friend.
Absolutely.
We're trying to go from product
to lifestyle, though.
That's why we're spending our
money in sampling and events,
because that way, we could
connect with people.
Look, you put yourself at risk
when you sample.
You are a supplement
that's making claims.
You talk about clarity,
you talk about energy,
you talk about focus.
And so when people see that,
that's what they're expecting
and that's what
they're hoping for,
even though you,
as a neuroscientist, know
no two people are gonna
experience it
the exact same way.
Right.
So if you sample, you put
yourself at significant risk.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thanks, Mark.
Listen, what you have
achieved and overcome,
I mean, there's no end
to what you'll do.
But, for me right now,
I'm kind of like this.
When I'm like that,
I have to say I'm out.
So, you know, for me,
there's a massive gaping hole
of how are you gonna
scale this.
But love you guys,
love the success so far.
For what I know,
I'm willing to take
a flier on it.
I'll give you
a million dollars...
Yeah.
...for 20%.
It's a flier.
I think your valuation
is stinky‐poo‐poo.
It's ridiculous.
But I like the premise
of the business.
I prefer
the vertical aspect to it,
that you found your market.
That business alone
could be good.
Here's my offer.
I'll give you $750,000.
I want 50 cents in royalties
off every unit
till I recoup
a million dollars,
and I want
the 5% equity now.
Oh, my Lord.
Chen:
Thank you for that offer.
Gonna respond to you,
Robert, first.
Yeah.
Do you want to meet halfway,
at $10 million valuation?
♪♪
I'd go up to
a $7 million valuation.
[ Sighs ]
We couldn't do 7.
I'm so sorry.
We can't do that.
Yeah, I think
it would be unfair
for the other investors
that came in.
O'Leary:
They're not Sharks.
[ Laughs ]
No, but they are
an extension of our family.
Sharks are expensive,
my friend.
Look, it's not your family.
They're investors.
100%.
And I think
I bring more value.
I mean, I love you guys,
but I can't do it at that rate.
I'm out.
Okay.
We appreciate it.
Well, then, all roads lead back
to Mr. Wonderful, as usual.
And they all have
potholes.
‐What do you want to do?
‐[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Oh.
I ‐‐
♪♪
I don't think
we could take your deal, Kevin.
You're making a big mistake,
my friend.
Guys, thank you very much.
Thank you so much
for your time.
Thank you so much.
♪♪
Those were great guys.
Love you, dude.
Love you, too.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, we're all about...
more, more, more.
More, more, more.
And the Sharks
definitely wanted...
Too much more.
...more, more, more.
Too much "more, more, more,
more, more, more, more."
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business
seeking to capitalize
on a popular kids trend.
♪♪
Aww! [ Chuckles ]
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Shannon.
And I'm Sarah, and we're
from Evanston, Illinois,
seeking $90,000 for 15% equity
in our company...
Seriously Slime!
Sharks, I know what
you're thinking ‐‐
"Seriously? Slime?"
[ Chuckles ]
That's right, Sharks.
We are serious about slime.
And you should be, too.
If you have children between
the ages of 4 and 12 years old,
chances are,
they've asked you to make slime,
buy slime,
play with slime,
or they've watched the endless
videos online about slime.
Slime is everywhere!
And it's not going anywhere.
But let's face the facts ‐‐
slime is messy.
It's messy to make,
requires a lot of ingredients,
and when things
don't go well,
kids tend to go
a little cray.
And that is why we created
Seriously Slime,
where our motto is...
"Let them make slime!"
At Seriously Slime, kids get to
experiment with slime
in a fun
and play‐driven environment
where there are no looming
concerns over that mess.
Now, Robert, we understand
you have a birthday coming up.
Whoo‐hoo!
And we heard
you wanted to celebrate
with Seriously Slime.
Thank you.
We're honored.
We are hoping
you would come up
and make a personalized slime
at our mobile Slime Shop.
‐Yes!
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Thank you.
Herjavec: Hello, girls!
Mobile Slime Shop.
Bam. Bam.
Alright!
Valko:
This is gonna be fun.
Making slime
is a three‐step process.
And the first step is
to make the slime itself.
You're gonna stir this.
Can I have you stir that?
Yes, you may.
Like a chef.
You're just gonna stir until
all the ingredients are mixed.
[ Chuckles ]
For the next part,
you're gonna pick it up
and knead it like bread.
Oh.
How do I knead it?
You can pull and fold
and pull and fold.
And you're gonna do this
just for a minute or so.
And we have another slime
ready for you
if you want
to start personalizing.
Alright.
‐Do you want any glitter?
‐Do I want glitter?
Of course!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, wow!
McDermott: We do have products
we sell in the stores.
Look at the color!
‐Are you okay with this?
‐Beautiful.
Finally, Robert,
the truth comes out.
Robert,
you're a slimeball.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: Aww!
That was awesome, girls.
Thank you.
Valko: Thanks, guys.
Love you guys.
Bye‐bye!
O'Leary: There's a lot of slime
on the market, right?
‐Can I smell yours?
‐There's tons of slime.
So, at Seriously Slime,
our model is
that we actually started
by doing mobile parties,
partnering with businesses,
and then opened our ‐‐
But your model
is to actually have events.
‐Yes.
‐It's a party...
‐Correct.
‐...they make slime.
We are
an experiential company.
So, that's
a service business,
and it's within
a geographic region, right?
So, we are in Chicago ‐‐
Evanston, Illinois ‐‐ right now.
Our goal is to license
Seriously Slime.
Have you licensed
any yet?
We have not yet,
because we are so new.
We started seven months ago
with an idea.
Nothing wrong with that,
but, I mean,
to turn that into a licensed,
leveraged play requires a brand,
because people
that are gonna basically
license or franchise
from you
are looking for
national marketing support,
so they acquire parties
in their region.
Well, they're obviously not
there yet. Where are you now?
So, right now, we've been doing
mobile birthday parties
for the last seven months,
and two months ago,
we opened up our own
Seriously Slime shop.
We have gone through all
the paperwork to be a license,
and we've gotten
a ton of requests.
So, let's just look
at the events business.
How many events have you done,
what do you charge per event,
and how much revenue
have you generated?
Sure.
Well, since we started,
we've generated
$28,000 in revenue.
$23,000 of that has been
in the last two months
since we opened up our shop,
but that's only because
our capacity to have more events
has increased.
Before we opened our shop,
we had $5,000 in revenue.
What do you charge
per party?
$300 to $350
for an hour.
‐$350?
‐How many kids?
Does that include
the product?
Yes.
That includes everything.
How do you take that
and make it a bigger business?
Just last year,
there were 25 billion views
of slime videos.
That's a different animal,
though.
That is the interest level
of this activity.
It's fair enough
to say that,
but now you're talking
to investors.
So, you want me to give you
$90,000 for 15%.
Nobody is going to franchise
or license from you,
because you haven't made
any money yet.
♪♪
No. I hate it.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Got it.
So, at our home,
we've bought kits to make slime,
and it's a huge mess.
Yes.
And we've gone
to parties
where they teach the kids
how to make the slime.
How do you differentiate
yourselves?
Well, I mean, slime
is so popular
that everybody's looking for it
in their communities.
Some people might be doing it
in their existing businesses.
We're the first one
that we know of that's
dedicated to 100% ‐‐
But, Shannon, you're not
answering the question.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
The demand is there,
but the challenge is,
other people can create
these businesses.
McDermott:
Can my fifth‐grade niece
start a slime company?
100%, and she can do
a few family parties,
and it's sweet.
If someone wants to create
a business around this,
you work with us.
We'll give you
lead generation.
How are you gonna do that?
You're not a brand yet.
Valko: That's why we need the
investment, so that we can begin
our marketing campaign
to go out in the communities
and start recruiting
these licensees.
So, the question becomes,
"Can you make money
from just a shop?"
Yes.
We started with $500.
We haven't invested anything
in this, outside of $500.
Good for you.
That's awesome.
‐And it's just the two of you?
‐And it's just the two of us.
Let me give you
an idea here.
Look, the place
that wants kids to come ‐‐
with their parents,
in particular ‐‐ are malls.
Malls need a reason
to attract traffic.
So true.
And if you can
bring parents in,
if you can just let the kids
there while the parents shop...
Yep.
Mm‐hmm.
...they'll give you
the space for free.
Yep.
We already have plans
to open one in a mall.
But you don't want
to start licensing it
to a bunch of other people,
because your obligations to them
will overwhelm everything else
that you're doing, right?
Yeah.
You've got to take
one step at a time.
It's not for me, specifically,
so I'm out,
but I think
it's a great opportunity.
Thank you, Mark.
Shannon, it was super fun.
I could see the parents
doing it with their kids.
But it takes time
to build that brand.
You know, you build it out,
you prove the model.
I think if you can get more
retail locations, it can work.
But, you know, money
doesn't grow a business.
Right.
Money is the accelerator
to a great plan.
Yeah.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
Listen, you don't always have
to do millions of dollars.
You can have
a nice, solid, good business
that brings the two of you
a great income.
And it makes you happy
and it makes others happy.
This could be
a great business.
And it just could be that.
But I don't think
it's investable for me,
and so I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Completely not something we're
pitching as a separate business,
but we've also made these
cute little Slime Babies,
which are...
Super cute.
...storage containers
for slime.
And we just made them
because we wanted the kids
to have something
to keep their slime in...
Super cute.
...because they put it in
plastic bags or containers.
They love it. They want
to bring it with them.
They love it.
They want to take it
to school.
Shannon and Sarah,
I think the best thing
you have going is this,
and let me explain why.
In our household, we do not
allow slime anymore...
[ Laughs ]
...'cause so many carpets,
so many pieces of furniture
have been destroyed,
and you cannot
wash that stuff out.
Be the guys
that sell the pickets
to the people that are doing
the gold rush.
All the slime
all over the world,
sell them
the slime containers
so that the slime doesn't go
in the wrong places.
That's a great idea. You could
sell it online on Amazon.
That'd be a great
little business.
These might actually be
a stronger business
than any of the other things
you have.
Slime containers ‐‐
that's a great idea.
And there's a need that you're
solving for, which is...
Yeah, absolutely.
But I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
But, guys, thank you
for your passion.
Thank you.
And maybe
we'll visit you in Illinois
one of these days
with our kids.
‐Good luck, slimeballs.
‐We love you all.
Thank you.
Bye, guys.
‐Love you, too, you guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Take care.
‐Congrats.
We're gonna continue to bring
the joy of slime to kids,
and the joy
that it brings to parents
to get it out of the house ‐‐
one slime at a time.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a safer way
to control pests.
♪♪
[ Chicken clucks ]
Jacobs: Hi, Sharks.
I'm Jessica Jacobs,
and this is Angel.
My name
is Zac McDaniel.
This is my wife, Jana,
our children,
Zara and Jennings.
We're from
Okarche, Oklahoma,
and we're seeking $100,000
for 10% equity in our company.
Sharks, we have
three kick‐ass generations
of family farming
under our belt,
and now we're ready
to help save the planet.
♪ Dunh‐dunh‐dunh duh! ♪
[ Laughter ]
As farmers,
there's one problem
we share with
the rest of the world.
Those pesky bugs getting
in our homes and our gardens.
Bugs are gross!
And you don't want them
in your house, do ya?
I don't.
Most of the time,
people turn to pesticides
filled with
poisonous ingredients
that are harmful to children,
plants, and animals.
That's why we decided
to create...
All:
First Saturday Lime!
A completely eco‐friendly
insect repellent.
Jana: Designed to safely
repel insects,
First Saturday Lime
is insanely effective
without ever jeopardizing
the health of you, your babies,
or your furbabies.
Or feather‐babies!
[ Chuckles ]
Not only is our product
so safe,
it's so easy to apply.
Simply spread
First Saturday Lime
around the exterior
of your home
to create a strong
but safe barrier,
like Zara's doing
around the chicken coop.
You can also sprinkle
a light layer of our formula
on any plant, garden,
or surface.
We've built this business
from the ground up,
and now the only thing
"bugging" us
is needing the funds
to put First Saturday Lime
in the hands of families
around the world.
So, Sharks,
who wants to join us
and say goodbye
to nasty bugs
and hello to protecting
your family, plants,
and animals?
[ Clucks ]
[ Laughter ]
‐So, we can touch it and all ‐‐
‐Yes.
‐Yes. Absolutely safe.
Here you go, buddy.
Thank y'all so much.
Wait. We want
one more chicken imitation.
Herjavec: Thank you, guys.
Great job.
Oh, Jennings.
One more "buh‐gock."
[ Clucks ]
[ Laughter ]
So, the premise is,
if I take powdered lime,
which is what this is ‐‐
a commodity, right?
Is that all it is?
It's actually
a proprietary formula.
I read what it is,
and it's ‐‐
O'Leary: Why don't you just
tell us what it is?
Well, what's the secret,
if Lori knows?
I don't know if we want
to blow anything.
It's citric acid, correct?
It's on the label. What do you
mean, "blow anything"?
[ Chuckles ]
Zac: Citrus acid
is the active ingredient.
Yeah.
It acts as
an insect repellent
and an antimicrobial
for odor‐causing bacteria
and algae.
‐So, citric acid with lime?
‐But it's so incredibly safe.
Mm‐hmm.
So, I would have
no fear whatsoever
to sprinkle
this anywhere?
Right.
What's with the name
"First Saturday Lime"?
Jacobs: Well, it's
a once‐a‐month application.
Greiner: Oh.
So on the first Saturday
of every month ‐‐
Repeat customers!
...we go online
and we remind customers,
"Hey, this is a perfect time
to re‐lime,"
and then they can share
their stories and results
with people.
That's cool.
Tell me a little bit
about yourself.
We are a third generation
in the limestone industry.
Our father
had the idea for it.
He's no longer with us,
but he was working
with universities
and various co‐ops,
and he started
this formula.
And then he passed
nine years ago,
and Jana and Zac,
they took over the farm,
they grew the company,
and they also made it
sustainable.
We built a factory,
and we have just exploded.
Farmers in America ‐‐
do they know
that citric acid is
a common insect repellent?
Is that widely used?
So, lime is
fairly common,
but what we did was
we created a version of it
which acts
as this magic formula.
Do you have a patent?
There's patent pending utility
on our factory.
So, we built a factory ‐‐
On the factory,
not the product?
So, it's the secret process
on how to utilize the lime
so that it works
in this manner?
Yes.
And how much
does each bag cost?
The 20‐pound bag
is $19.99.
What's it cost you
to make?
$1.60.
‐Wow.
‐There you go!
‐Whoa!
‐Yeah, there you go.
‐I have a question, too.
‐Great margin.
You got my citric acids
flowing
when you talked about
those margins,
and I want to keep talking
about the business.
Ew!
What are you going to be doing
in annual sales this year
at that margin?
This year, we're scheduled
to do $350,000.
Good for you.
And next year, based on
our current run rates ‐‐
so, last month's sales ‐‐
we should do $600,000.
So, you did $50,000
last month, basically.
Yes, but ‐‐
You're basically
selling these bags online?
Is it all online,
Jana?
Right now, our split is
80% online, 20% retail.
This year, so far,
what are your actual sales?
This year, our actual sales
are $150,000.
But you said $350,000.
Those are projections?
Yes,
and that's based on ‐‐
our last two months' rates
are $50,000.
O'Leary: It's not a lot.
Are you having a hard time
explaining the benefits
of this product?
No, it's great.
Are you kidding me?
‐It's not great.
‐It's nothing.
Jana: Well,
we signed vendor agreements
with larger distributors,
but we really said,
"Okay, we need a strategic
partner to go after this."
What if a child puts it
in their mouth?
It's absolutely safe.
This is not to be eaten
by people, correct?
Right.
Thank you very much.
Correct.
I can order a bag
for $19.99.
It costs $1.60 to make.
Do you provide free shipping?
Do I pay for the shipping?
This thing weighs about
10 pounds.
Jana: We do provide
free shipping.
What does it cost
to ship it?
About $10.
Whoa!
So, we have ‐‐
It's very heavy.
We are negotiating our rates
right now again,
based on ‐‐
our volume is so large.
We can get those down.
So we are making it
even lower.
We believe
in this product.
We want to create a healthy
alternative for families
and their homes
and gardens
so that they can
keep the bugs out.
I think you guys are coming
from a genuine place,
but I think you don't know what
you don't know at this point,
and it's gonna be
an uphill battle.
I'm out.
Thank you so much
for your time, Robert.
Okay, so,
the amount of education
that's gonna be required
to scale this
to make it a big business
is a formidable amount of work
because you've got
to explain
why a frog and a Saturday
and a lime
have anything to do
with each other.
That's just not a journey
I want to go on.
I wish you the best of luck.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Mark, I know this isn't
necessarily right up your alley,
but I also know that
you're interested in
what we're saying here.
See, look, guys,
presentation was great.
You made it clear
that the product is good.
The challenge is,
I just don't know
the lawn and garden business.
I just don't have anything
significant
where I can say
"Here's the accelerant.
Let's just go."
So, I think
it's a phenomenal business,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I appreciate it.
Congratulations.
Greiner: Okay.
The fantastic thing
about this product
is that it is safe.
So I'm very interested.
And it's so easy
to apply.
I know the hardware space
very well.
I think
this could be a hit,
but I think you need
to change the packaging.
And I need the message
to be more clear.
I'm gonna make you a bit
of a Sharky offer, though.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Lori seems interested
in Zac, Jana, and Jessica's
eco‐friendly insect repellent,
First Saturday Lime.
I'm gonna make you a bit
of a Sharky offer, though.
Because I love the product
from the get‐go.
But you need a lot of help.
Is there an offer
in the future?
So, my offer is
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000,
but I need to be
a third partner.
Well, thank you so much
for that offer.
We are very grateful.
And I think we can work together
to meet in the middle.
So...
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
Lubetzky: Guys,
these are my thoughts.
I think I am out,
unless Lori wants
to do this together,
in which case, I would consider
helping add value
with certain channels,
with certain marketing issues,
with certain
promotional issues.
Listen, I like Daniel.
I think that he also
would be helpful
in a new product
getting out there.
So I'm happy
to have Daniel in with me.
So, then,
that's two Sharks,
but we're gonna be
a third partner.
Well, based on what we have
our counts already,
we foresee a large profit
next year
of at least $200,000.
So would you do 20%
with the two of you?
Alright, here.
I want you to look me
very closely in the eyes, okay?
[ Laughs ]
Look at me.
You looking at me?
"Look me in the eye."
‐Yes.
‐Okay.
You say you're going to do
$200,000 next year profit?
Yes.
Why don't you change that
and add several zeroes?
Right?
We could do
at least $2 million.
So, you've got to think about,
what do you want to do?
You're going to sell
so much more.
And you don't
even have any idea
of all the things
you're gonna face,
so it's just gonna be
a road
that's gonna require
a lot of engagement,
so I really, personally can't
take any less than what ‐‐
Jana, they're selling
pretty hard.
What do you think?
Let me just say ‐‐
we came in asking for 10%,
and you went to 33%,
and then you talked about
how much money we could make.
So we're hoping
we might be able to meet you
just a little bit more in
the middle there, based on that.
What if we did the $100,000,
the 33.3%,
but we will help to fund
your purchase orders?
So you won't have
to worry about that.
Are you good with that?
I agree with that.
Bankrolling purchase orders.
It can be a lot more money
than you were thinking ‐‐
and more than
I was thinking.
It's the same pig
with different lipstick.
But we're happy
to do that.
You're still giving up 1/3.
Well, but it's not easy.
Yeah, but they don't need to
dilute themselves every time.
Right. Or go beg for a bank
to fund you ‐‐
You're still giving up
1/3.
If you would do it
for 25%,
I think
we could make it work.
25%.
You want to do it?
♪♪
No.
We're in it together.
There's two Sharks.
O'Leary: Wow.
I'll do the deal.
♪♪
Done. Deal.
‐Wow.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Oh, my goodness.
‐I love you guys too much.
It's too fantastic.
Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
‐It's too fantastic.
‐Thank you so much.
O'Leary: You got it.
Whoo!
Jana: Our dad would be
so proud of us.
And we can make Mr. Wonderful
a lot of money.
Yeah, and make the world
a better place, honestly.
Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Honestly.
That's what we're gonna do.
♪♪